[Music]
a last nanosecond kill and look at the
guns aw peas phonetic they're ready to
shoot some tops as they cross the middle
it's gonna be a challenge and not in
this lifetime he is destroyed look at
what apex sees here ah I love a good
sharp
well aged full-bodied unpasteurized
cheese strat that's right guys this week
on best-of we're taking a look at some
of our favorite of the meanest cheesiest
strategies in all of these sports
whether they worked or not this is the
kind of stuff you just love to hate now
how exactly do you define cheese as it
relates to gaming well suffice to say it
has to be high-risk high-reward
and most importantly high tilt factor
it's kind of like art you know it when
you see it and if you are interested in
the full definition of cheese as it
relates to gaming well we do have an
entire video on just that so make sure
you check that out too and well not all
of us may like cheese it's become an
accepted part of every competitive game
so join us as we take a dip into a
deliciously tilting fondue of cheesy
plays from overwatch League of Legends
dota 2 and my personal favorite CS Gouda
it's definitely gonna be that side of
the map and once they call this time
they go for this it's good a chance
already to close it out you might as
well you've got a kid off of a cake
I said this will be have heard though
coccyx not gonna peak boost instead
that's a clever way oh my goodnes a very
clever way well done
renegades well done nifty box again no
idea a nifty and the site is gonna close
it down and a goddamn sexy style will
they smoke it though there's no smoke so
guess they weren't but they will run
boost across this is great here we go
complete failure James Bob Bob football
the price is wrong [ __ ] patience game
coming in again spot them coming out of
suite doors while he's here he sees them
now they're straight heads up they have
no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's gonna be a
since you mentioned it the other members
of the team have been able to lift up
their socks they're doing it again Jane
thank you sir he hasn't got oil on his
shoes again my goodness maybe this is
what struts are for you want to practice
it oh come on cave not like this double
star layer them and NIV they can buy an
a half boat including and also sniper on
get right here I'm really wondering
about get rights position right now all
the way in the back there is the auto
sniper really gonna be useful from this
position sure if they do stuff like he's
expecting but if they get into the bumps
on them they are walking in right now
he's looking for the shot here it's from
a face well there's the one kill that's
a good start here but they're
challenging you they're fighting they're
not scared yet right or we get two or
three kills looking for
14 to 7 there you go he would say his
hat it's like I don't even know how it
does it but the thing is there's two CTS
on both sides Smiths with the auto
sniper trying to get those shots spam it
across but still no contacts oh my god
the flash actually helps Wow just super
coordinated looking to do Salomon
Freiburg already over at a yeah and
they're gonna hold this one so tightly
the the Molotov czar coming out as well
as the names but this time this noted
Tetris can't ride he taking very taking
fall with the auto sniper
he just needs ties and that's gonna be
yet hey when you're the most annoying
sound in the world now we've got five aw
he's picked up against the fire
eight caves of Navi phonetic I certainly
having a grand old time here the first
seven bottles fanatic right now they
just don't care
they've got eleven rounds on CT side
Kabul the second kill reply search all
of the teams they've been treating
already and watching they all know what
this feels like but how do you get out
from under real close from all of my
stuff he's now on the other side with
the knife is he really gonna try to snap
he's gonna go down
JW on the other side to pick it up
though aw he's shot to take him down and
now it's on ceased one on three he
hasn't got the ball he hasn't got the
time he's simply out of luck now ah that
was pure csgo ricotta now let's move on
to League of Legends cheese shall we get
ready for some party bushes and some
pocket picks from both gosu and these
guys oh no gauge is gonna get caught out
here by Ocelot it will be gone so
actually there to get your dues used IOT
gosu actually popping his own otiwu oh
my god can't the salty backed it with it
wow they were not expecting that
SK just got it destroyed a compa salty
time did with the gaza walls he timed it
with the spray wow wow wow wow
yeah well figures going the playoffs
something tells me he'll get an MVP or
two more brush I saw bliss come in to
play then you own them as you find them
right away
they help you I'm hiding from what on
Portland's adult hide-and-seek League
where does everywhere like it's really
difficult for reckless to do that as
long as misfits have any sort of
pressure now they've even more Oh golly
Oh My Jesus done on my meds Govind now
we have to go Corky no all of all of
Galu Elsa Webber I'm a mother are you
serious remain serious is it gonna win
us the game boss we could see the Cokie
talk again wow that's a vain midlane
into Italian pushing for the in hitbox
is the one to step forward that Bari
will take it up to the moment he comes
caps
exactly what you want from your main man
in a fight like this house comes up huge
got any rich yeah look great
yeah women women women holy cow oh happy
so something we have seen from teams
with like a lot of push games like now
things like towards the bottom side
meaning that there was no chance believe
us - it's the least silent tip
meanwhile of truth they want to kill
that bot lane ready for a turret dive
number one here we go if they can do it
Kirill is able to find enough cuz
they'll even come out they grab the
first blood orgy and bacon - a few
moments later and the most important
thing you belong to is the fact they
build up this very big minion wave to
see on the screen and as soon as the
wave is hitting the tower they are
instantly diving stubbing arty from
getting experience teleport comes in
from Archie but now he's found himself
in a very rough situation the turret is
gone orange eel alone and the damage is
there we've seen echo do actually quite
well against Rumble once he can get to
spectres cap but when we're taught olive
who has that's the pushing lanes they
actually have done
to lock miss horse are they really weird
I don't care about my last point they
can play safe and play aggressively
arrows land on the wolf but is just
gonna be too much damage too fast also
worth noting is sort of sort of par for
the course itself didn't crowd a little
forth here's the jump in a few more
attacks will do it and that's first
that's flat shebang but he's still
sloped down there's the harpoon there's
the chase down and gorillas gonna make
it rain gonna be all the damage he needs
gorillas getting the kill guys some of
those League of Legends plays never get
old but if that flavor of MOBA isn't
quite your taste well we've got some
dota2 mozzarella that should be more up
your alley even something like a come
cut you need some damage you need some
teeth I left some things solomid cos
you'll survive the trade with the earth
by catching taqueria there's another
earthquake coming up goddamn once taken
thinking
the grapes are coming but the fall
stopped out allowing Phaedra never lost
faith in another earth by coming out
from singsing more fruits and more macro
fire down
he's cutting these meat brain down here
for the totem some slowed him down a
little bit get out of the fire man
another they just control them Fiji
even with them notice they get down just
be careful oh the career oh my god in
before nervous as well one of these here
you just do each lane look it just goes
another Lane cleared see this is what
motion oh he almost died there the
glimmer came just in time
Oh nervous you can't discern any larger
oh you never should really found
abortion oh okay that happened now
they're picking a gyrocopter Rubik which
means that you're gonna be able to split
the experience really evenly they pick
it you can see Dendi smiling right now
he wanted it bad and poppy gave it to
him thing to continue to push they're
not done Mac still hasn't even been used
there's over run all the way back to the
base of the fountain fountain though he
doomed the chant that's a much better
choice
ranch business away and they oh there it
is yeah
bananas override it was too strong
he's like one of the only boy who said
we couldn't count to three already
he could deal with physical damage he
cannot deal with the magical damage she
will
[Applause]
so walks over a solitaire sickles him a
little bit but there's another one in
lane he's gonna walk over it had to
disrupt maybe not towards set this up as
well and this time strike though they
will get the kill and they will lose
their techies um wing that's overbought
GG wings get stopped and oh my god are
you kidding me oh it's really happened
noob at the first level one Roach and
what feels like forever and they've got
the arrow to help assist with this do
not think that this is a level one Roach
team at all not in the least bit this
would be the greatest Scout in the
history of Scouts of somehow secret
found this good luck catified all buddy
good luck and have fun indeed Kaka
moving in for the last couple swipes
easy-peasy level 2 alright newbie let's
see so level 2 on the Mirana level 2 on
the Ursa and it is little too on KB Tusa
Wow wait time I haven't some 23.5 great
way to start it by giving them that
you're gonna try and chase it down this
guy's got an aegis you think he's
stopping for anything at all the apps
are all I didn't draw first blood you'll
be firing on all cylinders guys Shh it's
a secret
envy told me after they saw vici gaming
in the mini Titan in game 3 he said that
was disgusting
if I have a chance I'm gonna do the same
to them but that's your date thing there
they gonna get scouted like rtks guard
against a Russians halfway through does
he can play gold level 1
how does this work now
[Music]
applause really hurting ha nope I lied
I'm the convergent tribe whole shebang
VG's islands of gold
favor of beachy gaming the level one ro
chaga tea scattered app you want to be
getting those wards out making sure that
there's no rewards blocking all your
camps if you're looking to pull if
you're looking to do anything else
you've got to keep your eyes open for
that one and Wow admiralbulldog give it
a freebie there's a small blood patch
where Admiral bullet your MP and it is
it is actually trapped because they came
to check for it now the Sun picker is
that I know they're gonna bring it down
oh boy now when the beat is the Swedes
they pull something out of the bag and
feet is going to go down as well Oh toy
hunter no one has ever done that no
one's ever done that in the history of
DOTA guys as you know Roshan only drops
cheese after his third death but we kind
of think icefrog should have made an
exception for those level 1 kills now
let's take it away from the MOBAs and
back to the FPS genre with overwatch
these plays are so cheesy they're gonna
make you wish for a goat's cheese meta
see we did there and getting that Reaper
out of the way was up to 73 mm over that
are we gonna see the classic fashion of
the moving platform I bet we are
it's a mobile turret it's a solo cute
classic you know it you hate it for
quick play and there it is doing work
with the bastion he gets to evermore low
as well as a nano boost for ride art but
it's over time they need to get on to
the point and they
we have done it are you serious on the
cheek got Sebastian up there too Clavin
he's waiting has passed it right now
cause he saw on the point and that's
gonna be an old team all bad will it be
a cap over tall already built up the old
tank take time goodbye ever boy you're
not gonna make it and that does it take
four LW blue what an epic cheese we can
dream I mean they could run the ERISA
actually running the the reason and the
diva here it could work for a little bit
modified is he actually gonna roll out
of this okay this is the scape Peter
tried circle around where are you going
oh this is sign up from postilion small
he's gonna either switch to widow-makers
i'ma call this the merry-go-round
because it makes me laugh the shooting
range
completely smashed together covers
matched DPS is real is real homeboy this
summation Bastion where they setting up
for this is a new Symetra by the way the
rework teleporters into play long it'll
even the light ground this is how they
going to pull stock side up that
position and they get you key to booth
or on a man this is a pocket stratton
aha again the pressure is here like you
said leap frogging for then they saw
your response signed is on the previous
mike he's got great sight line aids are
set up look at this and they can just
keep feathering adam on and off this
point jammer does out to sign though and
that huge stock sided a bit big room to
breathe
ain't even know how he knows what the
shoot at here that he just keeps holding
down that let's play there we go on to
this next high ground this track
downside is no room they cannot get out
of it they've gotta get kills like we
said stalemate as long as dark senator
alive or decock commit to the point pool
pump doesn't get back you ready for a
seal the top headshot out they don't are
that color you are happen and the big
bad light pole wraps truly alone on
those pointers 8 up
sit with those cannon shots and they
have cracked a tooth
is a pocket stretch connected there for
a moment
stalkers like it's okay guys I got
protected the walls up let's not go out
but stay in your read save the
introverted thing ice block up into the
front to block a little bit more another
wall I mean they're giving it content to
that yeah the car can be moved its this
is actually hilarious it's actually kind
of cool because if you try to get in
there and commit you're gonna get hooked
this is actually really cool this is the
cheesiest thing I
[Music]
hmm gumption they were attacking
aggressively down the main entrance in
overwatch League Pitcher had a seal from
Arisa
okay look at the compositional fighters
has changed to a triple tank for this
defense and the reaction is going to be
a 12-yard movement okay okay they stay
behind this Arisa so it's gonna be
difficult to take this out with the
composition they're running that's right
Jake on the run now but he can't run
fast run to our pr9 attack well guys
that is all for the best of eSports
cheese you love to hate
now don't forget to hit that like button
and subscribe to the channel so we can
make a little cheddar and I'll see you
next week these plays are so cheesy
they're gonna wait energy futures the
hope everyone else like not in eSports
is just like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
that person